[Musique]
bonsoir are we there yet
où en sommes-nous aujourd'hui où en
sommes-nous dans la connaissance du
monde la recherche de cette connaissance
de cette compréhension de cette
explication du monde c'est une grande
aventure qui dure depuis plus de deux
millénaires et qui continue aujourd'hui
et la question c'est de savoir justement
où nous en sommes et ce que nous sommes
près du but c'est à dire est ce que nous
sommes près de comprendre le monde
alors évidemment comprendre le monde
je crois que c'est un désir qui a existé
toujours et partout dans toutes les
civilisations mais il s'est passé
quelque chose dans notre civilisation
disons au vième siècle avant
jésus-christ à peu près avec des
philosophes de la nature qui s'appelle
les présocratiques qui ont voulu aborder
cette question d'une manière rationnelle
et ça c'était nouveau et ce souci de
rationalité c'est-à-dire d'introduire
des raisonnements finalement pour
comprendre et expliquer comment
fonctionne le monde
eh bien on peut considérer que c'est le
début de la science pas vraiment une
science au sens où l'entend aujourd'hui
mais au moins le début de la recherche
scientifique et à partir donc du vième
siècle avant jésus-christ pendant toute
l'antiquité grecque par exemple et puis
ça va continuer après d'une manière que
je vais expliquer différentes écoles de
philosophes de philosophes de la nature
comme on les appelle c'est le nom qu'on
donnait si vous voulez aux scientifiques
à l'époque ont émis des hypothèses ont
essayé de construire des systèmes
d'explication du monde
alors ce qui est important c'est qu'ils
ont mis en place une sorte de cadre et
qui est toujours le cadre dans lequel
nous fonctionnons aujourd'hui un cadre
qui permet précisément 2
d'aborder cette question de la
connaissance du monde sur le mode de la
rationalité
alors ce cadre c'est quoi c'est
d'adopter des grands principes des
grands principes
par exemple ça peut être l'amour et la
haine la condensation au contraire
l'expansion la symétrie l'harmonie ou le
chaos le hasard ça dépend des
philosophes ça dépend des écoles de
philosophie quelques quelques unes de
ses idées marche très bien d'autres ne
marchent marchent moins bien et puis
elles se mélangent on l'est on les
adopte on les rejette
et ça donne différents systèmes du monde
différentes explications du monde à
l'époque
la deuxième chose c'est de savoir de
quoi est fait le monde de quoi se
compose le monde par exemple de l'espace
de l'étendue le concept d'espacé pas
vraiment établie chez les grecs
une étendue donc dans laquelle vont se
poursuivre les phénomènes pour les uns
par exemple pour les atomistes grec
c'est le vide
et puis savoir dans ce cadre qu'est ce
qu'il y a il y a de la matière et puis
la matière et bien on va penser que ces
faits d'éléments fondamentaux alors par
exemple pour platon aristote ça va être
quatre éléments fondamentaux qui sont la
terre l'eau l'air et le feu et tout ce
qu'on voit autour de nous ce sont des
combinaisons ces quatre éléments pour
d'autres qu'on appelle les atomistes
greg bas ce sont des atomes qui sont
répartis dans un espace vide illimité ça
ressemble à ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
les particules élémentaires
donc voyez il ya plusieurs manières
d'aborder le monde qui sont en
concurrence
et ce sera celle de platon et d'aristote
qui va s'imposer à l'époque non pas
parce qu'elle est meilleure mais pour
des tas de raisons historiques qui va
durer à peu près jusqu'à la renaissance
et puis il ya un troisième point après
les principes après le contenu c'est les
lois et finalement les lois elles vont
être exprimé d'une manière mathématique
parce que très tôt dans cette histoire
dans ce développement de cette aventure
cette aventure culturelle pour expliquer
le monde on voit apparaître la nécessité
d'utiliser les mathématiques pour
expliquer le monde alors ça ça a été dit
depuis le vième siècle avant
jésus-christ par exemple pythagore tout
et nombre mais aussi platon que le nul
n'entre ici
géomètre ensuite on aura galilée le
monde est écrit en langage mathématique
et puis newton qui va mathématisée le
monde qui va mathématisée la physique et
puis à stein steira et ça continue ça
continue encore aujourd'hui donc on a
une vision
on a déjà une prévision du monde ou
plutôt un ensemble de vision
concurrentes dont aucune ne marche
vraiment très bien et qui sont pas tout
à fait non plus fonctionnel on a ça déjà
dans l'antiquité grecque
et puis ça va durer pendant presque deux
millénaires où on va voir que ces
conceptions sont remises en cause il ya
des concurrences on montre que certains
trucs ne marche pas que d'autres marches
finalement et on aboutit au xvième
siècle au xviie siècle à la grande
révolution newtonienne qui est le
fondement de la physique ou enfin si
vous voulez et un système vraiment qui
va se mettre en place et qui va
fonctionner et ce système est bien c'est
newton donc qui va le mettre en place et
c'est encore une fois le début de la
physique moderne et aussi de
l'astrophysique moderne bas newton va
reprendre tout ça mais il va le préciser
c'est à dire il va dire il ya un cadre
pour le monde et ce cadre c'est l'espace
et le temps
il ya un contenu c'est des particules
c'est de la matière fait de particules
puis aussi des ondes des rayonnements
enfin ça dépend aussi des conceptions de
l'époque il ya rien peu des débats sur
cette question
et puis tout ça et mathématisée d'une
manière très précise et newton il ya
beaucoup de mathématiques dans cette
fondation de la physique et il ya des
lois des lois qui vont être exprimées
mathématiquement mais toutes les notions
physiques sont représentés par des
notions mathématiques donc les lois sont
mathématiques et ça va marcher d'une
manière extraordinaire ça va très très
bien marché et dans la physique il ya
toujours deux aspects ya l'aspect
pratique c'est ce qui aujourd'hui nous
permet d'envoyer des satellites autour
de la terre ou des sondes qui se pose
sur mars ou de faire de fabriquer des
ordinateurs de fabriquer des transistors
des lasers tout ce que vous voulez de
fabriquer des systèmes qui permet
d'implémenter à l'intelligence
artificielle bon tout ça ces résultats
d'une recherche fondamentale en physique
mais il ya aussi dans la physique
la connaissance du monde comment
fonctionne le monde et donc newton nous
donne un cadre de pensée pour le monde
dans le monde et un cadre l'espace et le
temps et puis il ya un contenu
les particules par exemple qui obéissent
à des lois et ça va très bien marché sur
un plan pratique ça marche un petit peu
moins bien sur le plan conceptuel parce
que cette conception du monde
newtonienne elle n'est pas du tout
parfaite et du coup au xxème siècle pour
différentes raisons
ça va être de nouveau remis en cause on
va avoir une révolution fondamentale
dans la physique qui va complètement
balayé le cadre conceptuel le cadre de
pensée newtonien pour en établir un
autre en fait pour en établir un autre
c'est pas tout à fait vrai parce que il
va y en avoir deux différent et
concurrent à savoir qu'au xxème siècle
il n'y a pas une révolution scientifique
mais il ya une double révolution
scientifique d'ailleurs d'un côté nous
avons les théories de la relativité
générale dans les années 1950 1910 1915
jusqu'à 1920 établi essentiellement par
un seul homme qui est albert einstein et
de l'autre côté nous avons la physique
quantique dont einstein est aussi un
fondateur mais il ya beaucoup d'autres
protagonistes comme d'irak freudiger
eisenberg bord et d'autre des noms que
vous avez peut-être déjà entendu et ses
deux nouveaux cadres de pensée en
physique vont donner des conceptions du
monde complètement nouvelle et
complètement différente de la conception
newtonienne et le problème c'est que ces
deux conceptions du monde sont
différentes et elles sont même
incompatible vont très rapidement que
nous dit par exemple la conception la
relativité générale
elle nous dit qu'il faut abandonner
certaines notions newtonienne il faut
abandonner la notion d'espacé la notion
de temps il faut les remplacer par une
notion d'espace-temps qui est quelque
chose de vraiment différent c'est à dire
quelques fois on va entendre que
l'espace temps c'est l'espace et le
temps tout simplement non c'est quelque
chose de beaucoup plus subtil que ça et
qui change complètement notre perception
des choses c'est à dire que ce que nous
appelons le temps qui nous permet de
nous rassembler ici à de nous donner des
rendez-vous et d'être à l'heure au
rendez vous et bien c'est une sorte
d'illusion que nour et crayons qui
marche très bien à notre échelle mais
qui ne marche pas du tout à l'échelle de
la physique fondamentale donc la
relativité générale on peut dire c'est
un
j'ai du cadre conceptuel de
l'explication de la conception du monde
newtonienne au profit d'une nouvelle qui
va nier l'espace et le temps et qui va
remplacer sa part une notion nouvelle
qui est l'espace temps dans laquelle la
conception de la matière fait de
particules n'est pas vraiment modifier
si on regarde maintenant l'autre volet
de cette révolution scientifique c'est à
dire la physique quantique c'est
complètement différent
le cadre newtonien va être également
rejeté mais on va garder l'espace et le
temps et c'est la matière qu'on va
changer c'est la conception de la
matière c'est à dire selon la physique
quantique la matière n'est pas faite de
petites particules qu'on peut localiser
dont on peut dire elles sont là elles
ont une certaine vitesse et tout mais
c'est quelque chose d'un peu floue vous
avez peut-être entendu parler de ce
qu'on appelle le principe d'incertitude
et bien l'incertitude de la physique
quantique c'est finalement ce qui
exprime que la conception que l'on a de
la matière c'est à dire du contenu de
l'univers n'est plus du tout celle de
newton
elle est nouvelle donc voyez d'un côté
la relativité générale de l'autre côté
la physique quantique rejette
complètement nous oblige à rejeter la
conception newtonienne la remplace par
une nouvelle conception mais le problème
c'est que ces deux conceptions ne sont
pas les mêmes et elles sont même
antagonistes
alors si elles sont différentes mais
elles peuvent pas être toutes les deux
vrais puisqu'elles sont contradictoires
donc est-ce qu'il y en a une qui est
vrai ou est ce que ni l'une ni l'autre
n'est vrai et il y en a une que l'on ne
connaît pas encore qui serait la bonne
alors ça c'est ce que pensent la plupart
des physiciens et évidemment cette
conception
il la cherche tout le monde cherche
quelle est la bonne théorie physique qui
irait au delà de la relativité générale
et au delà de la physique quantique qui
serait beaucoup plus unifiée beaucoup
plus globale qui nous permettrait
d'avoir une conception unique du monde
alors vous avez peut-être entendu parler
de la théorie des cordes de la gravité
quantique d'autres approches qui ont des
noms un peu barbare qu'on appelle les
twister où la géométrie non commutative
peu importe finalement
mais ça veut dire qu'on cherche que les
physiciens théoriciens cherche une
nouvelle conception du monde aujourd'hui
alors évidemment toujours avec l'idée
qu'il va falloir l'exprimer par des
mathématiques donc sans doute avec des
nouvelles mathématiques
donc aujourd'hui on cherche une nouvelle
conception du monde
on cherche une nouvelle conception du
cadre dans lequel se joue les phénomènes
peut-être toujours l'espace temps mais
un espace temps qui n'est pas celui
auquel nous pensons aujourd'hui une
nouvelle conception de la matière qui
est sans doute un peu flou parce que la
physique quantique nous dit que ça doit
être floue et finalement aussi des
nouvelles lois qu'ils s'expriment sans
doute au nouveau au niveau de nouvelles
formules et de nouveaux outils
mathématiques et ça c'est le travail des
théoriciens des physiciens théoriciens
aujourd'hui qui fonde la physique
conceptuel et donc pour répondre à la
question de départ où en sommes-nous
aujourd'hui
et bien voilà nous en sommes là nous ne
sommes pas au bout du chemin la physique
théorique la physique fondamentale c'est
une activité qui continue il ya des tas
de physiciens théoriciens qui font ça et
croyez moi c'est extrêmement intéressant
et c'est un grand plaisir
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]